ça c'est vachement bien et ce qui est
super c'est qu'effectivement il n'y a
pas de bulle pour le coup non donc je ne
critique pas la bulle je ne critique pas
la meilleure attitude c'est vrai que
c'est bien parce que du coup on
sensation d'immersion
on est quand même c'est un truc
vachement grands
[Musique]
juste derrière moi là vous le voyez
là-bas on a le lancement la présentation
française dé nouveau smartphone milieu
de gamme et entrée de gamme de samsung
c'est la nouvelle série à à 10 à 20h15
en fin je te vois 80 je vous emmènerai
tarière vous allez voir c'est vachement
intéressant il ya plein de nouveaux
produits et ça c'est plutôt cool
[Musique]
cela va t-elle ouais on n'avait que
mathilde de samsung aujourd'hui qui est
très heureuse parce qu'elle appelle
nouveau produire nous montrer le poids
ni tes petits bébés en fait c'est
tranquille ouais c'est la nouvelle gamme
à la nouvelle gamme un éclat elle est
annoncée dans son intégralité
ouais je te propose qu'on se fasse un
petit peu après le tour du propriétaire
avec l'ensemble de ses six pros dit on
va s'y produire ici produit beaucoup
donc une gamme alors pour recentrer déjà
chez samsung historiquement il y avait
une gamme jim de l'entrée de gamme gamme
et milieu de gamme et le haut de gamme
et la note
c'est ça qu'on est là parce que dure son
petit benoît c'est parfait du coup la
gabegie disparaît c'est çà et là gamma
couvre les deux en fait la gamme j ai la
gamme à fusionner pour ne faire que la
gamme un hockey parce qu'en fait cette
gamme avait vraiment une très bonne
image acceptable
tout va les uns et au niveau un petit
peu dynamique
en fait par exemple si on prend le
galaxy à 50 descendre la représenter en
fait à monter en gamme plus tu vas vers
le haut plus tu vas être
sur le produit le préau commence par
quoi par le bus par le à 10 à 10 après
avoir lieu à 20h à 50 à 70 et pour finir
le à 4 heures le à 80 alors oui ça à 20
e pour quoi essentiel généralement c'est
ça l'essentiel
voilà ce qu il existe également une
version avant mais nous en europe sera
uniquement de la version avant
d'accorder russie pour contacts en
termes de far marocaines cause un plus
bon ça marche alors quelle est la
différence principale entre ses
différents produits parce que du coup il
y en a beaucoup et c'est pas forcément
évident quand le consommateur comme ça
ils répondent chacun un besoin du temps
le galaxy à 10 donc un écran de 6,2
pouces oui là on va être tft on va avoir
uniquement un appareil à l'arrière donc
là c'est vraiment l'appareil photo
efficace oui c'est le smartphone pour
entrer dans la gamme samsung 2019
[Musique]
ensuite on va avoir le galaxy avant
qu'il a va être le smartphone le plus
compact de la gamme d'accor qui va être
de 5,8 pouces ont vraiment le plus
compact qui agrémentent rayant à la main
ensuite on va voir à l'arrière donc deux
capteurs un classique de 13 mégapixels
et le second pour deux ultra grand-angle
on a également un bar de la charge
rapide le galaxy à 40
lui aussi va être tout aussi contacter
donc on va être sur 5,9 plus là on va
avoir du super amoled donc c'est à
partir du galaxy à 40 pour montre dans
le super amoled de capteur à l'arrière
donc en de 25 lots de huit donc pareil
pour le fera quand on est à la bombe va
également avoir une caméra frontale qui
va être puissant et de convertir 25 méga
pixels le galaxy a 50 ans donc celui ci
un écran de 6,4 poussins pouces super
amoled bien évidemment on va retrouver
également le lecteur d'empreintes qui
l'être sous l'écran pour que pratique
rapide pour déverrouiller et à l'arrière
apparition donc du triple capteurs
[Musique]
le galaxy à 70 donc c'est un petit peu
le grand frère du galaxy à 50 on va être
sur un écran qui est plus grand donc 6,7
pousse toujours du super amoled le
lecteur d'empreintes sont sous l'écran
et là on va être à l'arrière pareil sur
un triple capteurs par contre au niveau
au niveau des pixels en maître sur 32 et
32 également sur la caméra pour contrer
ensuite en termes de batterie c'est là
aussi la différence avec la sentence ça
va être convaincre sur une technologie
ultra échange rapide pour 25 versus 15
sur les autres en claquant et une
batterie de 4500 milliards eur
[Musique]
je pense à lui à 81 à 80 donc se produit
il a été annoncé dans le piège
voilà milan pourra partir en plein cours
à partir de là mon pote donc ce produit
il a une innovation majeure parce que
maintenant on n'appelle pas forcément le
prochain taxi pourra porter l'innovation
on veut on peut les rendre disponibles
directement vacances et brooks un e
cette innovation majeure est présente
sur cette innovation
ça va être donc notre caméra rotative à
comment ça fonctionne
il suffit simplement de saipem et donc
la caméra rotative violences s'élève à
0,7 seconde
donc c'est vraiment ultra rapide et donc
l'intérêt vraiment de cette caméra
rotative en fait c'est d'avoir en fait
les mêmes capteurs à l'avant et à
l'arrière donc la même qualité et les
mêmes fonctionnalités
si on va avoir un petit atelier qui
illustrent donc cette caméra rotative
nous allons commencer à fonctionner
comme le geek ici le montre sa tour donc
c'est tout simplement ici sont classés a
beaucoup saluent nous est là et on 07
secondes
je bascule donc ces trois compteurs à
quoi ils servent
on va avoir donc le capteur principal
capteur principal donc de 40 inégal
pixel art absolu sur les photos de tous
les jours on a quoi ensuite on va
m'entendre je me le fera quand on
luttera gandon ouais donc 123° la 78
degrés sur le capteur principe à croquer
et ensuite le troisième cas trilogiq la
nouveauté
j'essaie innovation qu'on va vers un an
of time of light bangkok donc c'est un
autre portrait 3d en fait ça permet
d'analyser les scènes en 3d comment ça
fonctionne en fait sans voix un éclair
de lumière sur l'objet et ça calcule la
distance et ça te permet en fait de
dissocier tout ce qui va être notamment
pour les maux de ventre et d'associer le
fond qui va être en 2d du sujet qui va
être en 3d et donc ça ça trois bénéfices
trois bénéfices principaux donc le
premier ça va être la mode portrait qui
va être encore plus précis au niveau du
scénario le 2 ou le deuxième penalty ça
va être que tu vas pouvoir faire des
vidéos avec un arrière-plan foot est
d'accord pour mettre en avant toujours
ton sujet et enfin le dernier c'est un
peu plus avec internautique il ça va
être la mesure rapide tu vas pouvoir
mesurer d'un point a à un point b par
exemple
l'existence est également conçu un objet
au capteur time of light savard a battu
le rouge t'as vu à notre ami potter ou
pas là je vote en train de mentir
carrément allez vas y prends le crayon
crédibilité allons avoir notre mode
portrait ici qui va être encore plus
précis grâce à ce capteur donc la mise
au point peut se faire avant ou après et
donc nouveautés on va retrouver donc la
vidéo en mode portrait également avec ce
flou d'arrière-plan que tu peux
également réglé quand on tourne le flou
d'arrière plan qui en font le troisième
donc ça va être tout ce qui va être
mesures rapides connaissent donc c'est
internet on calcule à tout tu veut
mesuré par balles ok tu dois savoir et
de la mesure et ou services directement
donc ça calcule l'air les distances etc
et je peux également par exemple si je
mets ce point ici je fixe et je peux
calculer la distance par exemple jusqu'à
mon pot à crayons donc là tu as 46 cm 47
hockey l'autre 14-16 l'ultra grand tombe
donc là on va être sur 123 degrés je te
paie pas qu'on regarde là on est sur une
vue classique donc on va être sur 78
degrés et ensuite je bascule sur une
ultra grand-angle et la magic les femmes
mais elles apparaissent et là on est sur
123 degrés et donc ça sera également
disponible sur la caméra frontale
quand tu bascules windows est la même en
fait c'est ça c'est la mairie et est ce
que tu peux faire aussi du jeu avec une
party gaming
je sais que ça existe potentiellement ça
va arriver oui parce que tout ce qui va
être réalisée de lentilles etc
ce capteur va être idéal pour ça qu'elle
coule la nativement nativement n'aura
pas de jeu si on finit de paris de cette
caméra on va retrouver donc 2 à
l'intelligence artificielle ont tué trop
capable de reconnaître jusqu'à 36
méfiante et en fonction adapter les
réglages les réglages les contrastes et
que c'était au petit nice de complément
de prix c'est sans pression donc ça
c'est quelque chose qui s'activeront se
désactive
comment cette dernière que quelque chose
au niveau de la vidéo on en retrouvait
également l'action carmat est similaire
à ce qu'on peut retrouver sur un ace 10
maintenant une nouvelle génération
stabilisateur optique parfait en termes
de performances sur les commandes en
termes de performances sans produit qui
va être puissant si celui-là 128 giga de
mémoire également huyghe al rahma
d'accord aux termes de fluidité pour
combattre gaming etc
c'est par définition ensuite au niveau
de la batterie dont correction 3500
milliards
petite nouveauté là aussi on n'arrête
pas le progrès m on va être sur une
batterie de 25 watts pour la recharge
c'est ça d'accord donc ça va être très
bien parfait et un exynos s'imagine
intérieur non non c'est pas vrai non
qu'est ce qui se passe au stade rené 50
alors d'accord ok de la recharge en
guise de signe du conte forcément le cas
de la recharge rapide double carte sim
ou sans carte sim intérieur sur un mode
double carte sim genou droit hier à
chaque fois les hauts parleur mono
j'imagine oui ok ça marche c'est
vachement bien parce que c'est vrai que
ça permet d'avoir un smartphone avec un
super surface d'écran voilà ça m'arrive
l'écrou la donne le dernier point majeur
en fait c'est ce qui permet cette camaro
cative l'avantagé
[Musique]
montage salle est donc cet écran
vraiment immersif qui refoule dans 93 %
de surface d'affichage un boulot donc à
vraiment 04 eur donc même le lecteur
d'empreintes qu'on va être sous l'écran
des mois qu'il faut être toujours comme
ça que ça se passe
donc cet écran vraiment il va être
complètement immersif
ça c'est vachement bien et ce qui est
super c'est qu'effectivement n'y a pas
de bulle pour le coup non nokia
je ne critique pas la bulle 1 je ne
critique pas la deuxième faute attitude
c'est vrai que c'est bien parce que du
conte sensation d'immersion
on est quand même sur un truc qui
vachement grand et ça c'est hyper hyper
libérale en termes de qualité d'image on
est déçus ont de super amoled full hd +
way pour le qu'au niveau des contrats
c'est vachement bien
c'est vachement bien petit bourg breton
qui est tout petit béria c'est ça c'est
très sympa et donc absence de deux
capteurs vraiment surtout de cette face
avant moi même au niveau du haut parleur
mois elle sera en appel enflammé des
vibrations en lutte et les fans qui va
permettre d'entendre d'accord ok ok
c'est un smartphone qui est dispo quand
enfin mis d'accord et la qatari 650
659 c'est bien c'est joli comme ça non
mais ça que le design est sympa alors
c'est quoi c'est un doux envers derrière
non soir oui on est sur du verre et du
métal ans on est sur du verre du métal
on a un côté qui est complètement
incurvé ça c'est beau le bouton de
volume j'imagine donc pour l'allumer
aucun capteur d'empreintes digitales qui
n'est pas ultra trendy qui se fait avec
la ligue 1 oblige
anthony je vais t'apprendre de des pieds
après marche en tout cas bien précis
c'est ça ok c'est cool ça va être
chouette produits choix de produit brut
testera plus tard donc je vous invite à
vous abonner
[Musique]
l unique 6 e à 20 e pardon à quarante à
cinquante à soixante dix à la 70e et
voilà pour ce nouveau smartphone à
l'euro assez testé d'ici quelques temps
le à 50 ans le testera d'ici peu de
temps donc je vous invite dès maintenant
à vous abonner comme ça vous saurez tout
on testera un peu plus tard lorsqu'ils
sont sortis fin mai début juin les
autres modèles et notamment le à 80 avec
sa caméra qui tourne tous les côtés ça
c'est assez intéressant dites moi
comment voulez trouver est ce que vous
trouvez ça intéressant est ce que c'est
cette caméra bien que vous puissiez
utiliser d'un côté ou de l'autre ça vous
botte est ce que ce système étatique
vous trouvé ça intéressant surtout
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce très
grand écran par le contenu multimédia
vous marquez tout ça bien évidemment
commentaires j'habite à consulter ma
playlist qui doit s'afficher ici ou ou
juste rien qui parle des différents
smartphones du moment
et puis bien évidemment je donne rendez
vous dès demain pour de nouvelles actu
smart forintek et compagnie à des
matières